>> YOU LOVE "CHICAGO FIRE" ABOUT
THE BRAVE MEN AND WOMEN IN THE
WINDY CITY.
YOU COULDN'T TEAR YOUR EYES AWAY
FROM CHICAGO P.D.
NOW DICK WOLF IS BACK WITH A NEW
DRAMA ABOUT ANOTHER GROUP OF
CHICAGOANS STRUGGLING IN THE
FACE OF AN UNFORGIVING CITY.
>> READY?
>> LET'S DO THIS.
>> DICK WOLF'S CHICAGO IMPROV.
AN UNFILTERED LOOK AT THE WORLD
OF CHICAGO'S IMPROV COMEDY
SCENE.
>> WE NEED A SUGGESTION OF A
HOUSEHOLD OBJECT.
ANYTHING YOU HAVE AROUND THE
HOUSE.
>> DILDO.
>> SOMETHING OTHER THAN DILDO,
PLEASE.
>> TWO DILDOS.
>> UNFLINCHING IN ITS DEPICTION
OF THE REAL LIVES OF CHICAGO
IMPROVISERS.
DIALOGUE RIPPED FROM REAL LIFE
IMPROV CLASSES.
>> HEY.
GREAT OBJECT WORK OUT THERE.
>> OH, YEAH.
ALL OF YOUR SWEEP EDITS WERE
PERFECTLY TIMED.
>> STOP IT!
WE'RE ALL ON THE SAME TEAM.
>> CUT.
DO YOU KNOW WHO'S IN THE
AUDIENCE NOW?
GREG AMICO.
>> WHAT THE HELL WAS EVERYTHING
THEY JUST SAID, ASKS THE "NEW
YORK TIMES."
AND THE BOSTON GLOBE WONDERS WHO
IS GREG AMICO?
SHOULD I KNOW WHO THAT IS?
WATCH AS PEOPLE WEARING PLAID
BALANCE LOVE AND AMBITION IN
AMERICA'S NUMBER THREE COMEDY
MARKET.
>> I HEARD YOU'RE DOING STAND-UP
NOW.
>> JUST OPEN MIC.
>> I GUESS YOU'LL HAVE WHAT YOU
ALWAYS WANTED -- THE STAGE ALL
TO YOURSELF.
>> HEY, HOW MANY PEOPLE EVEN
MAKE IT TO MAIN STAGE?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHO THE BAD GUY
IS HERE.
>> GUYS, I BOOKED IT.
I'M FILMING TWO COMMERCIALS FOR
LOU MOLNATTI'S.
>> CONGRATS, HOLLYWOOD.
>> THE ONLY SHOW WITH REAL
CHICAGO FACES AND BODIES.
I WANT TO SEE PRETTY PEOPLE
COMPLAINS THE HOLLYWOOD
REPORTER.
WHILE USA TODAY SAYS, THE FIRE
IMAGERY WAS MISLEADING.
>> MY NAME IS JACKIE JACKIE AND
I WAS BORN IN A LOG CABIN.
>> DID DICK WOLF LOSE A BET?
WHY DID HE MAKE THIS, ASKS THE
"WALL STREET JOURNAL."
>> TOO MUCH IMPROV SAYS IMPROV
MAGAZINE.
IF THEY DIDN'T